the gig economy has really benefited
mutually benefited both you as a company
and many of the drivers right you talk
to many drivers who are able to have
different jobs on the side or able to
manage their own schedules there's been
a ruling by the California State Supreme
Court that may put that in jeopardy does
that jeopardize your business and are
you concerned at all about that ruling
well the ruling as a stance certainly
does jeopardize our business the
singular theme that I hear from our
driver partners what they love about
uber is they tell me uber lets me be my
own boss and they essentially get to run
their small enterprise the way that they
wanted to this morning my driver he
draws from 4:00 a.m. to 8:00 a.m. and
then takes his kid to school which is
really really cool and doesn't deal with
traffic at 4 a.m. etc so he's able to
define how he wants to engage with our
platform if he wants to engage or not
engage the rulli we think creates lots
of problems in terms of that model and
the cost it's something that we're
looking into but ultimately is my
personal opinion it's not good for our
driver partners and not good for us and
not good for the cost of transportation
going forward are you gonna take part in
appealing that ruling the ruling doesn't
directly affect us because the court
case wasn't about us but we're certainly
looking into it